There are essentially two parts to
building a Discriminative System.
We have to build an object model
that is a representation of each
of the training instances.
And here we're going to
be talking about images.
The methods that I'm going to show you
of course, the overall classification
method could be applied to future
vectors from all sorts of things.
That in fact if you take
a machine learning class,
many of you already have.
You learned about discriminative
classification for arbitrary.
vectors, so we'll spend a little bit of
time talking about features that come
from a computer vision or
an image element.
Right?
So you would use them for
biological data of describing genomes.
But the representation you might
apply to other kinds of pictures.
So you have to build that model.
And the second thing you have to do
is you have to train the classifier.
Then when you run this thing, what you
have to do is you have to figure out,
I need to generate new
candidates to test.
So I give you a picture.
What does it mean to say,
tell me, you know, what's in it.
Is it the whole picture,
parts of the picture,
we'll talk about that in a minute.
And then once I generate candidates
I'm going to have to score them.
I have to evaluate them with
a classifier of yay or nay.